America has a new president-elect who is
how should we put it unpredictable and
we're not doing very well with cyber
America also has the NSA which has a
penchant for spying on innocent citizens
there's no telling how the surveillance
state might change in the next four
years but if you're interested in
keeping your private communications
private there are some steps you can
take first up is an easy one what's that
you might already use it you also might
not know that it already uses something
called end-to-end encryption so only you
and the recipient can read the messages
you're sending that's because the
messages are scrambled and only the
recipient has the key required to
translate this is called end-to-end
encryption and it's great but it has a
vulnerability namely that somebody can
impersonate a recipient so whatsapp has
these security codes these let you
confirm that the person you're speaking
to is the infinite recipient another
great option for encrypted messaging is
signal the cypherpunks app of choice
same principle is whatsapp but signal
comes with a bonus disappearing messages
that means your messages are not only
encrypted
they're also ephemeral that's a great
thing for anybody who wants to make sure
their messages are totally secure
whether you're a journalist or a source
as for email check out proton Bay it's
based out of Switzerland so your data
falls under Swiss privacy laws instead
of American ones it boasts end-to-end
encryption and doesn't log your IP
address making it anonymous then there's
tor if you want anonymity across the
board this is for you
with Tor your computer never connects
directly to a site instead the software
redirects your requests to a bunch of
servers all over the world the last of
which is the one that communicates with
the site you're trying to access the
site never sees your IP address instead
it sees the IP of the last server in the
chain allowing you to browse anonymously
all of that said none of these tools is
perfectly secure
but if you're worried about the NSA on
Trump they are certainly better than
you're worried about everything else
there's always yoga